what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here as i
suspect it is for many of you because it
really has been a while here
my name is richard and this is the
channel where we talk about all things
data data science statistics and
programming so subscribe for all kinds
of content just like this if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell
that way youtube notifies you whenever i
upload a video
so again it has really been a while
since i've since i've uploaded over here
but
as i read some of the comments that have
come through and i read various things
that go up on medium and and other
publication sites i'm beginning to sense
a bit of overall anxiety about the data
science job market
now
i imagine a lot of that is more global
and macroeconomically based
like we're sort of coming into this new
environment following the pandemic a
winding down and figuring out what the
broader economy looks like after that
so
that carries with it all kinds of
different changes and and i mean there's
all this talk about the great
resignation going on people are leaving
their jobs
some jobs are going completely remote so
you've got all that kind of stuff going
on
but i'm also beginning to see in here
just talk about data science being
automated i feel like even more than it
used to be
so
i felt like it's worthwhile to to take a
deep dive in the data science job market
again
now anaconda that's the number one data
science platform in the world
they do this state of data science
report every single year i remember i
covered this last year the link to that
will be in the description of this video
but this is a publicly available report
it'll be linked in the description too
and anybody can go here and and download
this but it is a really good survey it's
really comprehensive and just to get a
little bit more of an accurate read on
what's actually going on in in the data
science world now i thought it would be
worthwhile to take a deep dive through
this
so before we get started here
smash the like button for the youtube
algorithm because it really does help my
content reach a larger audience and also
if you guys would be willing to support
my channel i have links in the
description of this video to my patreon
account as well as to my crypto wallet
addresses
now without further ado let's get
started all right so let's start with
some high-level executive summary type
of stuff
so
obviously a big focus throughout this
entire report is just understanding how
data science is changing and evolving
following the pandemic that much should
probably be obvious
but how this report was can was created
was
through a survey of 4299
individuals these people come from more
than 140 countries
and this survey was conducted from april
14 to may 5th of 2021
respondents came from social media the
anaconda email database and anaconda.org
now
ironically
this is a survey about data science but
we have to ask ourselves first and
foremost
was this survey conducted through best
data science principles i guess more
specifically
is this a representative sample of the
broader data science community
and i would say probably not i mean if
you look at the inclusion criteria for
getting in this survey i mean social
media the anaconda email database
um not everybody is going to all these
different things so
that's just one consideration and we'll
we'll look at this more when we look at
the overall demographic profile here
but i will say it is good that
students academics and those working in
commercial environments are all
represented here so again it may not be
a perfect representative sample but when
we speculate about what the data science
world looks like today and going forward
i don't like to make those kind of
guesses in absence of data obviously and
so this is certainly going to be better
than nothing
now as we get a little bit more insight
into who these people are we see what
countries they're coming from
blue means 55 plus respondents as the
color gets a little bit greener and more
yellow that means fewer respondents
so we see a lot of representation here
obviously from the us canada uh mexico
brazil western europe india australia so
on and so forth
as we look at respondent age
50 of people here are in the 25 to 40
age category
so
that's cool
i see here that uh 15
of respondents here have
no college whatsoever and in fact only
17 have some college
uh granted here though
uh some people here are in college right
now so keep that in mind
but in in various data that i've seen
before though on on the data science
community as a whole like in terms of
people working in commercial
environments
it seems that about 15 percent or maybe
a little less than that don't have a
college degree at all so i am glad that
uh some people without that are
represented here
in fact though i do think more than 10
of people in the data science world do
have phds so
keep in mind that 10 of respondents here
have have a phd so you would think to
have a fully representative sample that
you probably want to have more than that
but what are you going to do
and so
as we look at the primary job functions
of our respondents here
the single largest category here are
students
but we also see people who are working
as data scientists or even as business
analysts being represented here
granted these are far from the only job
roles that you can work in
when you're in the data world so things
like cloud engineers
data engineers
developers
uh line of business managers good to
have their input in here
and there's one of these donut chart
things here just just indicating where
people are in their current job level so
you've got people who are directors or
managers even at the owner executive
c-suite or vp level
and then you got people who are entry
level all the way up to senior is
typically the next level followed by
principal is kind of that midway a jump
between being at the senior level and
being at some kind of managerial or
directorial kind of function
now the next section of this report is
all about the pandemic and how that
specifically impacted data science
and the first question to dive into here
is did the pandemic impact your
organization's investment in data
science this is specifically
among those respondents who work in some
sort of commercial organization
and so for 37 percent of respondents
they say their organization did
experience decreased investment and
personally throw me in that 37 percent i
saw this myself
among everybody else there was 13
percent who were not sure
but for 50 percent of people
that investment stayed the same or or
actually increased
now it's worth taking a deeper look at
why individuals
said there was a decrease in investment
specifically i i want to understand that
a little bit more than the increase here
actually so
unsurprisingly a lot of this had to do
with fiscal financial reasons
so
the company had decreased budget
no team growth team layoffs in fact or
they just had project timelines that
were put on hold
and so this is not particularly
surprising to me
in particular because for a lot of
companies
data science may be sort of more
discretionary
or it's put into some sort of research
and development kind of category
and i i hate this term
but there was all this talk last year
about essential workers and who is and
isn't that
and where data science falls into that
into that discrete category may may
differ from one organization to another
and there's also no frame of reference
with the 37 percent of number like is
that is that high is that low was that
more or less than we expected
there's really no good way to answer
that question except to look to the
future 2022 and beyond and speculate
that
as
as we see more return to normalcy for
more companies
hopefully more companies sort of reach a
sort of equilibrium here they look at
their competitors who are succeeding as
they dive more into data and they
realize that this is a worthwhile
investment and i'm completely confident
that we are in fact going to see that
again in 2022 and beyond as we get
further and further out from the impacts
of the pandemic
now the next thing to look at is among
these individuals who work in some sort
of commercial environment let's
understand a little bit more about those
people
so
we come over here and look at what
industries these people are looking in
right off the bat as we just look at the
number of industries that are listed
here this is really broad
so
right off the bat the single biggest
category is tech at 10 of these
respondents followed by academic
consulting automotive banking
engineering
but there's there's a lot of different
industries here that are represented so
that's that's that's a really exciting
thing
now as far as how these people exactly
work as far as what that looks like from
day to day
let's start at the bottom here
so
for 19 percent of people they are some
sort of solo practitioner
so it'd be a little bit interesting to
learn a little bit more about how
exactly they're working as a solo
practitioner like
are they working in their own business
are they the single data scientist in
their company or business analyst or
whatever it is in their company
so that's that's that's pretty curious
to me
but the other 81 of people work in some
sort of team
so of that 81
the single biggest category of them
work in a team of six to ten people that
seems to be the biggest group here
now again with the six to ten people
here
maybe that's some sort of
cross-functional agile sort of thing
i know that's how i've worked personally
in the past where
you could be in a team but you have
analysts data scientists product owners
scrum masters
people who are more consulting on the
ground sort of people but that's
that's that's not not particularly
surprising there
now as far as
where in the organization their data
role sort of falls
we've got for 23 percent of respondents
data science falls into it
okay that's that's sort of interesting
for 16 percent of people data science is
regarded as a research and development
function
and then for eight percent of people the
next biggest category data science is in
some sort of data science center of
excellence sort of capacity
okay
then as it follows there's operations
finance maybe that one's just just
removed to me because i personally never
worked in
in any sort of capacity where i'm in a
data science
group and then it's under finance like
that that just seems weird and foreign
to me but i guess that's the next
biggest category
and then of course we had the really fun
how do data scientists spend their time
now i may kind of have to call bs on
this on this particular question because
we've got for
22
of people's time that's in data prep and
17 is in data cleansing
so if we kind of bundle those two
together because
both of those are sort of similar to me
we've got less than 40 percent of
people's time altogether is spent uh in
the data prepping and cleansing sort of
category
now the reason i say i may have to call
bs on that is
i
don't entirely believe that one i mean
if that's actually true that's
absolutely wonder wonderful and speaks
great volumes to how quality uh this
line of work is and maybe going forward
and actually we'll revisit this a little
bit later when we talk about automation
so again color me a little bit skeptical
on that because this i filed this under
the category of almost being too good to
be true
again if it is true though that's
absolutely amazing
so we've got the next 17 being in
reporting and presentation
15
is in data visualization
and then for the next
uh let's say 35
here this is in all sorts of modeling
activities so model selection model
training and deploying models
so where one of these starts and one of
these ends may not necessarily be be
clear but
speaking of 35 of
of time falling under the modeling
category uh is an interesting sort of
sort of categorization here
and as we talk about getting to
production here
as far as where people's concerns are
coming from here we've got 27 reporting
that their their biggest issue is
uh meeting i.t security standards
being that particularly in a lot of
industries like health care and finance
um privacy is a huge issue this one
doesn't surprise me at all
then we've got a lot of these people
reporting concerns as it pertains to
recoding models from one language to
another
so recoding models from python or r to
another language
isn't is a big category but with only
one percent less so it's not really a
significant difference at all we've got
recoding models from another language to
python or r
and there's a breakdown here of of how
people are reporting that based on what
their actual
role in their organization is
now we're gonna actually skip ahead to
a topic that i think is arguably the
most interesting piece of this entire
report which is
overall enterprise adoption of open
source technologies
so the pythons the rs the the julia's of
the world
and so in this question
does your organization allow the use of
open source software
a whopping 87 of respondents said yes
now that's huge to me that's that's a
really big deal and so that really tells
me like the older technologies like the
sasses of the world
they may be going the way of the
dinosaur here i hate to say i told you
so on that one but i did tell you so on
that one
so
also 65
of respondents said their employer
actively encouraged them and their team
to contribute to open source projects
now as far as what that actually looks
like
that means additional time dedicated to
contributing to these sorts of projects
funding specific to those sorts to
development of these sorts of projects
and team members who are dedicated to to
these contributions
now as far as securing the open source
pipeline what does that look like
45 of these respondents said they use a
managed repository
that really makes sense because that
cuts down on a lot of reinventing the
wheel sorts of things
there's manual checks against a
vulnerability database using the
vulnerability scanner so on and so forth
now as far as securing the open source
pipeline security and privacy and things
like that are obviously big uh
considerations
and so
as far as the roadblocks that people are
reporting for preventing their
organization's use of open source
fear of
cves that is common vulnerabilities and
exposures
uh that came up and that that that
doesn't surprise me again
places like healthcare and finance and
sort of these more old school
organizations where
privacy and security are of the utmost
concern
they are going to be the last ones who
are really getting behind open source
and just moving 100 of their pipeline to
those kinds of technologies
and listen i i get that and these are
things that that over time they're going
to be they're going to be worked out
over time
there's not wanting to disrupt current
projects in place that's another uh
unsurprising thing and then just lack of
knowledge or understanding now not to be
sort of crass here but a lot of this
pertains to sort of a sort of
just the demographics in age as people
come in and out of the data science
world i think so as you have older
generations who are retiring here for
whom open source technologies like
python and r that just wasn't part of
what they were working with
as this is replaced by
newer generations who
learned python and r as they were going
through school and they want to apply
those skills they learned uh in their
day-to-day work
you are probably going to see those
people become leaders and push for that
to be more part of
of just what their company does and how
they provide value day-to-day so
again that that 87 number i think that's
absolutely massive and as we see the
same
survey being done in in coming years
honestly that 87 is probably going to
become closer to 100
just as people
really see the value that open source
provides
speaking of the value that's provided
there
the very next section here is all about
python
now people always leave these comments
on my videos about oh you're an r fanboy
and
i
make no effort to hide the fact i love r
it will always have a soft spot to me i
actually learned it before i learned
python and i've been coding in it for
about a decade now and quite frankly
i was educated as a statistician
r was built for statisticians by other
statisticians and so it will always have
a soft spot in my heart
that being said
i can't deny and i don't deny
just how much python really is catching
on in the world right now
and
if we look at this breakdown here they
ask respondents how often they use the
following languages i always find these
charts kind of hard to read but there's
various categories for how often people
are using these things they get bundled
as always or frequently or sometimes
and if we add the 34
for always 29 for frequently and 22 for
sometimes
that means a whopping 85
of respondents here are at least
sometimes using python you've got
eleven plus four is fifteen percent of
people are rarely or never using python
but still that's huge and the very next
most commonly used language that's sql
we've got
15 plus 20 plus 27 percent here that's
62 percent of people are at least
sometimes using sql
then if you look over here at r again i
love r but only 27 plus 25 that's 52 of
respondents are at least sometimes using
r
so there's a huge gap there i mean
python is just eclipsing absolutely
everything at least based on this one
survey here
and now if we dig into why
why that's the case
a big reason here is that
71 of educators are teaching python and
88 of students are reporting that
they're being taught python in
preparation to enter the data science
and ml field
and now i could be wrong on this one
but i seem to remember seeing and
hearing several years ago anyway that
python wasn't really catching on quite
as much in the academic world there was
a lot of people in that in that in that
space who were being taught r or their
or they were being taught things like
stata or or matlab or things like that
but python wasn't really showing up
quite as much
and now they say that as the business
world adapts academia seems to adapt a
few years later so as the data science
as the data science business world
changes its needs
academia kind of takes a few years to
catch on to that and they change what
they're doing in preparation to get to
get people uh just just ready to
contribute in the business world
so
we may be starting to see that and that
may be a huge reason why python is
really picking up like this
now granted that's not the only reason
obviously so you've got things like
python's ease of use libraries community
just how easy it is to google things and
find the answers
um but another big reason is how how
important and how easy it is to deploy
models into production using the
capabilities that are provided using
python
next section here is all about data
literacy and business impact
so
the the header right up front here is a
lack of business knowledge is impacting
a data professional's role in business
decisions
but when you get into this breakdown
here it doesn't really seem all that bad
to me i mean we've got 53 percent of
respondents here saying all or many
business decisions are based on uh
their or their team's
insights then for 35 percent they say
some decisions are based on that so
right up front that that doesn't really
sound that bad when you break it down
that way
but
when you start asking this asking other
questions and so and sort of framing
this differently
you start to hear that 36 percent of
people say their organization's decision
makers are very data literate and
understand the stories told by
visualizations and models
but 52 percent of people say these
decision makers need some coaching on
the stories told there no surprise there
at all
and 12 percent of people say their
decision makers just flat out have
trouble understanding the stories told
by data visualizations and models
again that that doesn't surprise me at
all i tell the story on my channel a lot
but i've run into a very high-ranking
stakeholder before who had no idea
whatsoever how to interpret a scatter
plot
i'm not saying that that to make fun of
that person at all but i'm saying that
to kind of speak to some people know
their business and their domain really
well but they just don't have that
education or that training in in in all
these
things in the data world it's just not
their their education it's a foreign
world to them and so you're going to
have that gap there
so
oftentimes there's there's
it's easy to point fingers at people who
are data professionals and say well
they're not experienced enough uh they
don't know their business and their
domain well enough and to a great extent
that is true that is one of the one of
the motivations that i had actually in
starting this channel was to impress on
upon people how important the
communication and the domain knowledge
is
but that understanding does cut both
ways that is
clients or
people who are managers at these various
organizations that employ these data
professionals there needs to be a lot
more understanding from them
about the overall value that data
professionals provide as well as just
how to interpret things like
visualizations and models that
ultimately these things are complex the
idea is to boil complex things down to
things that are more simple and that's
things that all data professionals could
probably get a little bit better at
but my broader point here being that
that misunderstanding there can kind of
cut
both ways here
now as we dive a little bit deeper into
what's limiting our respondents ability
to impact business decisions based on
their job function
the number one thing that people are
reporting here is that business
priorities shift quickly
and
i'm sure those of you like myself who've
worked in data science capacities for a
while can relate to this one maybe
you've worked on a project for a while
it's really cool you're making progress
and then all of a sudden the rug gets
pulled out from under you and you've got
to go do something else
so that kind of thing happens
now for these next two
i have to wonder there may be a little
bit of a response bias with this one
because you've got for one category
which people are reporting a lot more
you've got decision makers at my
organization struggle with data literacy
and then for the next category you've
got i or my team can't effectively
demonstrate business impact
so i have to wonder with this one
again i've already pointed out that just
there being miscommunication and issues
from
people who work as data professionals to
the people that they're reporting to
there's probably a little bit of a of a
gap on both sides there and both people
uh can can do better there but it's also
probably easier to point fingers
uh like in the case here rather than to
say oh it's me who can't really
effectively demonstrate business impact
so i have to wonder a little bit about
kind of the bias of that that's that
that's in effect there so just something
to think about there
though like i said it cuts both ways
then we've got skills gaps and how
they're impacting decision making and so
here i like to look at the gap between
what enterprises lack and then what
students are learning or what
universities are offering
so
no surprise here enterprises don't seem
to be lacking advanced mathematics as
much as universities are offering them
and so i can relate to this one in the
sense that i learned all about minimum
various variants uh unbiased estimators
in the academic world can't say i've
ever used that piece of information in a
commercial environment
so there seems to be a gap between uh
enterprises uh needing big data
management and then universities
offering uh and big data management here
or business analytics or business
knowledge these seem to be some pretty
big areas of just just there being a gap
there and now let's talk about the
future of work okay so specifically data
science work but this is one of those
things that ties into the broader
macroeconomic environment here
so
according to the bureau of labor
statistics
data science is listed in the top 15
fastest growing occupations and it's
projected to have a 31
job growth over the next 10 years
so they always say in the financial and
investing world that past performance is
not does not indicate future returns and
certainly that applies here but
if the past is any indicator of the
future
then i'd say that that job growth is
probably going to be significantly
higher than 31 percent
that's just that's just my guess here
i could be wrong but that's that's
that's where i'm leaning on that one
now
there's all this talk
uh out out there in the economic world
right now about the great resignation
people are leaving their jobs and
they're going to other places where they
feel more fulfilled and this ties into
remote work too which is more of a thing
that people are being allowed to do
i could do a whole video about the topic
of remote work but that's that's a
little bit beyond the scope of this
video
but a big takeaway here is
32 percent of respondents in the survey
are looking for a job in the next six to
12 months
so
i've heard 40 percent of people in the
entire
um
economic world out there but 32 percent
of people is still a lot
and i will say data scientists tend to
be
on average
more
well-paid and more
and just
just people with a lot more options
than your average person in the job
market
and a lot of that has to do with the
supply and demand gap there is more
demand for data professionals in the job
market than there are than there is
supply there so
it gives data professionals a lot of a
lot of leverage and a lot of power quite
frankly
so there was a question about which of
the following do you think best
describes how leadership perceives your
role so
for 38 of people these data
professionals say
leadership perceives them as people who
explore data and ask questions and build
models that lead to better decision
making that's that's a good answer we've
got the go-to person for all things data
reporting and analytics
that's a big time red flag that's not
the position that you want to be in
because that's that's overwhelming and
that's unsustainable that's that's what
we call unicorn syndrome
and we've got people who build ai and
machine learning applications that's
only 22
um then we've got another red flag here
that's my data science work is valued
but they don't understand what i do that
that's not good because if leadership
doesn't understand what you do
uh you're not going to feel valued or
empowered in the kind of work that you
do and and it's going to lead to
problems one way or the other no matter
how high your salary is
then as far as
the student respondents out there what's
their biggest obstacle to obtaining
experience required for a career in data
science
so the single biggest category that
people are reporting is finding an
internship
and it is one of those catch-22
situations out there unfortunately where
you sort of need a job to get a job but
you can't get a job because you never
had a job in the past
so
that comes down to one of those
instances where if you're if you're a
student
it really is a numbers game and you just
have to keep chugging away at it keep
trying and eventually i'm confident it
is going to work out for you and it
comes down to some of the same economic
factors that influence the data science
world in general
there is more demand for data science
than there is supply of people who can
do that kind of work and there's a lot
of organizations who frankly they are
they they're growing and they want to
resort to cheaper labor that is it costs
a lot less to hire an intern than it is
a full-time worker and so
as as we recover more from pandemic land
and we go back to normalcy more and more
hopefully
this this problem gets alleviated more
and more
and now as we start winding this report
down there are some big questions in the
data science and the machine learning
and the ai uh spaces as a whole
so
question is what respondents felt was
the biggest problem to tackle in in ai
and machine learning
and so
the number one response here was social
impacts from bias in data and models
more on that in a moment as we talk
about what bias actually entails because
that's broader than a lot of people
realize that they're brand new to this
stuff
then there was impacts to individual
privacy that's a really hot topic in the
uh in the tech world right now
then there's a reduction in job
opportunities caused by automation
and so
as we asked the question is your data
science team planning to take any steps
to ensure fairness and mitigate bias or
to address model
explainability like how you actually
come up with this model in the first
place and then what's what's what's
suitable interpretation
for said model
i think you can go through the results
here and you see 30 of
uh people are planning to take more
steps to address uh bias mitigation in
the next 12 months and 31
for model explainability uh and
interpretability now they state here
that is a seven percent increase from
2020 as far as the
uh bias mitigation number is concerned
and so
it's really important just to just to
remind yourself here or if you're brand
new to data science as a whole that all
data has an unintentional bias insofar
as how it's collected and how it's
analyzed and just how it's filtered and
all these things like that these are
things which represent major assumptions
and these assumptions do create whether
they're unintentional or intentional
sorts of bias
in in the analysis
and these are things that just
downstream just affect all aspects of
the process whether that's in model
building or whether that's in just
explaining the results and so just
understanding how robust your results
are to these assumptions or to these
biases
understanding how these things affect
your results in the first place these
are very very big issues so no that's
that's that's a good thing that uh that
we're having these conversations and
talking about
about them
and then of course we have to cover
something that i thought was absolutely
fascinating which is the sentiment
toward auto ml in data science
so
actually it's not just auto ml it's
automation in general that is the
process of automating tasks involved in
applying machine learning to real world
problems in data science
so actually
55 of respondents hope to see more
automation and auto ml and data science
41 of people had no strong feeling
toward automation
but then only four percent of people are
concerned about how automation and
automl may impact data science
so this is really interesting to me this
is another one of these kind of i told
you so moments on my end where i've been
telling you on this channel for a while
that
don't hold out in fear about your job in
data science being replaced by
automation
my grand thesis has always been
yes there are certain tasks in data
science which are going to get automated
away
but this opens up more time just in
people's worlds where instead of just
spending all this time doing repetitive
tasks that can be automated
you can reinvest that time to do other
just more interesting things quite
frankly and then down the road
solving more complex problems and so
probably as automation grows you're
probably going to see more
job opportunities in the data science
world that's what i think and i'm gonna
have a big a confirmation bias moment
here as i see these results here but to
be fair i want to explore this just a
little bit more
so
the next question here is what is the
biggest myth about data science
so
the single biggest thing that people
responded here was that
data scientists will be replaced by
artificial intelligence soon people are
saying that's a big myth
but wait a second
so if we look back up here
there was this question about what our
respondents felt was a big a problem to
tackle in ai and machine learning and
there was a reduction in job
opportunities caused by automation
that didn't seem to be a big thing that
people were responding to that question
only 19 people said that was the biggest
problem
um but at the same time only four
percent of respondents are having
um a negative perception about
automation and automl and 33 of people
are saying that that data scientist
being replaced by ai soon is a myth
so
my read on this as i try to reconcile
all these numbers is that
people in the data science world aren't
necessarily worried about their own
jobs and their own work
but a lot of it has to do with
automating away
other people's jobs
so if you think about it just just to
give some examples here people
things like like like
self-driving cars there's a lot of
automation there maybe there's
automation around taking people's orders
at a fast food
joint or just things like that
necessarily as that kind of technology
just evolves
so automation is coming more into play
there as data scientists are building
out new products and services and
hopefully helping to pad the businesses
bottom line there
but there is a big social impact there
where
yeah that's great for a data scientist
they have a job doing that
but instead of having a delivery driver
or or an uber driver or or
just somebody who's taking your order
over the phone or or in person at a fast
food location
all of a sudden a machine is doing that
work instead of
an actual human being and so there's
fewer jobs available to all those other
people believe me i i understand that
that is a huge concern that's kind of a
it's easy to look at that as a not my
problem kind of thing as a data
scientist but you don't want to be that
person you want to understand the social
impact
uh as data scientists as data science
and artificial intelligence involves
there is a broader
societal cost to that so it's just
something to keep in mind and it's just
my read as i see all these numbers about
how how all these things come together
but
if you are a data scientist and you're
worried about your own job though
again i i've maintained for a while i i
wouldn't be data science will be around
for a while and frankly i think
automation is just going to make it even
more enjoyable for you
and so anaconda here wrapped up the
report by summarizing four big themes
for enterprises to focus on
number one python will continue to
dominate the data science field and
beyond
i see no evidence to the contrary of
that that that seems pretty clear to me
number two enterprises are ready to
contribute to open source innovation
that's enormously exciting that was the
single biggest takeaway uh to me here
number three sentiment toward automation
will continue to grow
again all kinds of considerations with
that that i just rambled about for a
while
and then number four preventing bias and
developing ethical data science is
critical
again just my take on that is always
think about whenever you do any kind of
data analysis regardless of how simple
or complicated it is
always think about what kind of what
kind of assumptions are at play in that
analysis what announce what what
assumptions did you make whether you're
thinking about them or not what impact
do those assumptions have and what's the
impact of the work that you're doing in
the first place
so how's your work actually going to be
used these are all incredibly valuable
questions
and huge credit to anaconda here for
conducting the survey
putting this report together and even
with concluding with these big themes i
thought this was a fascinating report
and there are some really really
interesting takeaways here so i'm gonna
leave it all there
let me know in the comments down below
like what your biggest takeaways here uh
here are
again this report will be linked in the
description feel free to read it
and just let me know down below what you
thought
so i'll leave it there smash the like
button for the youtube algorithm
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard
on data